"We are in full emergency," a doctor from the hard-hit Bergamo region in Italy said,...
...making a desperate appeal in a video message for help,...
...as coronavirus cases skyrocket in the country and hospitals struggle to cope.
Beijing residents cheered the fact...
...that China registered zero new domestic transmissions of the coronavirus for the first time...
...since the outbreak took hold in Wuhan late last year.
In Brazil, protesters bang pots and pans...
...to call for a better response to the coronavirus outbreak from President Jair Bolsonaro,...
...who has faced scrutiny for calling the outbreak a fantasy, but now faces hundreds of cases,...
...including among some lawmakers.
In Iraq, the country began its week-long lockdown on Thursday...
...in an effort to slow the spread of the new coronavirus.
Finally from Greece,...
...Tokyo 2020 organizers received the Olympic flame in a scaled-down handover ceremony in the Greek capital,...
...amid the coronavirus spread that has cast doubt on the global, multibillion-dollar event.